масштабна реформа вищої освіти на нас
чекає цьогоріч у п'ятницю кабінет
міністрів запропонував надати більше
можливостей для навчання студентів за
державний кошт мова йде про державні
грантові програми також пільгові кредити
і відповідний законопроєкт вже передали
до Верховної Ради а от що збережеться
класичне
і регіональне замовлення і хто зможе
здобути часткову освіту безкоштовно так
за державний кошт А хто зможе повністю
все своє навчання здобути за державний
кошт ми про це поговоримо з заступником
міністра освіти і науки з питань вищої
освіти Михайлом винницьким Доброго ранку
Добрий ран вітаємо гарний настрій попри
все Да нормально Даха А який має бути
має бути гарний зукриття мовимо друзі і
говоримо про освітній процес в 24-му
році в Україні от наразі є такі цифри
60% студент і вищів здобувають освіту на
контракті 40% на бюджеті тому і логічне
питання що зміниться у разі якщо
парламентарі все-таки підтримують
пропозицію Кабміну яку ми сказали вище
дивіться насправді сьогодні система дуже
чорно-біла та людина або вступає на
бюджет або вступає на контракт і різниця
дуже часто може бути там тисячна бала Та
от от Я складаю ЗНО мені вийшло там 74
по і це означає що я вже на на на на на
контракт 74,6 і я вже на бюджет попав Ну
дуже така чорно-біла система якщо я на
бюджеті це означає що я ще маю
можливість стипендії і там ну держава
платить все А якщо я на контракті ну
батьки платять Все або я плачу все ми
хочемо трошечки відійти від цієї системи
чорно-білої Отже це означає що так
залишається певна кількість для тих які
дуже-дуже класно вчаться дуже добре
вдають ЗНО дуже добре здають нмт от Вони
отримують стовідсотковий так званий ну
100%соткове держзамовлення або або вони
йдуть на спеціальності які реально
потрібні державі це мова йде про лікарів
про вчителів про деяких інженерів які
нам будуть потрібні для відбудови
держави там хіміки фізики того типу люди
які реально потрібні державі для такої
собі Якщо хочете інфраструктурних потреб
Але якщо ти хочеш Ти на журналіста Якщо
ти хочеш Ти на філолога Якщо ти хочеш Ти
на айтішника на на так дальше то там
працює включається система грантів що
означає система грантів що на під ставі
мого нмт чи ЗНО я отримую певну
кількість грошей гроші приходять мені
реально на телефон якщо ви пам'ятаєте
колись була є підтримка щось таке
подібне так от приходять на телефон і
тепер я йду до того закладу вищої освіти
до того університету який мені
подобається на ту спеціальність яка мені
подобається я підписую контракт але
частину мого контракту Я сплачую за
рахунок тих грошей які До мене прийшли у
формі Гранта тепер це означає що держава
сплачує дуже часто та там 50% 60% 80%, в
залежності від того які є бали на нмт і
в Цей спосіб Ми маємо можливість взяти
ті самі гроші які ми витрачали колись на
вищу освіту це дуже великі гроші які
держава витрачає на вищу освіту і
замість того щоб їх розподіляти
чорно-біло отримав бюджет отримав
контракт трошечки більше їх розширити і
в нас виходить десь приблизно на 40%
більше людей які отримують державну
підтримку але державна підтримка не
повна отже відповіда на ваше питання
зараз в нас 40 бюджет 60 контракт в нас
Ми хочемо дійти до того що в нас буде як
мінімум 60 від людей які отримують
державну підтримку Ну і певна кількість
людей які будуть дальше вчитися повністю
на контракті ну тобто гранти ще
закривають допомагають бюджетові
зберегти ресурс в тому справа іщо ми
говоримо про те що що фактично трошки
більш справедлива система от державні
гранти пільгові кредити яка різниця між
ними Чи це так і хто має право на ці
віться якщо ви тепер попали на таку
систему де де ви не отримуєте повну
вартість вашого навчання наприклад там
80% 80% навчання приходить від держави і
ви є в ситуації де вам треба закрити тих
самих 20%, 20% це може бути там 10 000
скільки там гривень а і ми на це
дивимося І кажемо добре якщо я з сім'ї
наприклад яка не може собі позволити на
таке я можу взяти довгостроковий кредит
кредит є на 15 років Угу за
пільговою пільговими відсотками там 3 5%
скільки там має бути але що дуже важливо
що дотепер такі пільгові кредити були
але вони оператором цих кредитів були
заклади освіти і в результаті воно
ніколи правильно не працювало мова йде
про те що банки Державні банки будуть
Займатися тим що вони можуть надати 15
років кредит Отже я вчуся скажімо собі
там 4тири роки 5ть років отримую там 10
000 в рік від банка 10 000 в рік від
банка я взяв в мене залишається після
завершення навчання там 40 000 В мене є
кредиту Я маю 15 років щоб його віддати
при дуже-дуже маленьких відсотках Тобто
це бу будуть певні банки які будуть
працювати по програмі пільгових кредитів
так і просто треба буде розуміти які
саме саме так і і тут фактично Державні
банки важливе питання для ветеранів
війни дітей загиблих героїв дітей з
інвалідністю та дітей з сиріт у
законопроекті які запропонований ми
обговорюємо спецумови зарахування
довичів які дивіться дуже важливе є що
людина яка е якої батько чи чи чи матір
На жаль загинув на війні це особа яка
має ну держава супроти тієї сім'ї має
особливі відповідальності і очевидним є
те що дитина загиблого воїна має мати
право вчитися а це в першу чергу на в
першу чергу першочергова можливість на
зарахування подібна ситуація є з
пільговими місцями для інвалідів для
дітей сиріт для для інших пільгових
категорій на що я хочу тут звернути
увагу що та грантова система про яку ми
говоримо Вона працює для тих
спеціальностей яких потреба в яких
держава не може їх прогнозувати для
інших
залишається державне замовлення державне
замовлення - це означає що держава
платить за все навчання і держава так
само що дуже важливо має забезпечити
перше робоче місце Отже якщо я вчуся на
вчителя Для прикладу Так я вчуся там
чотири роки я отримую підвищену
стипендію в зв'язку з тим що держава
умовно кажучи замовила цього фахівця я
отримую всі пільги які мені потрібні для
того щоби Ну ми хочемо максимально
отримати якісних вчителів і в даному
випадку ми так само будемо забезпечувати
робоче місце після того як особа
закінчила це навчання Отже в даному це
це важливо що ми до Великої міри
розподіляємо ринок
е освіти на таким чином що є ті які
йдуть за грантами А ті які йдуть за з
традиційним бюджетом і й бюдже же є
насправді ну ще зазначимо що цей
законопроект лише подали до Верховної
Ради його ще не прийняли так об маль
часу перескочимо на таке питання дуже
важливе наразі стипендії українського
студента вишу складає 2000 грн А підвище
на 2910 грн а як зміниться в цьому
питанні ситуація
цьогоріч тому що ми бачимо що ну як
можна прожити студенти дивіться я думаю
що ту треба розуміти що ніхто не не
очікує Що що студент буде проживати на
2,000 грн і в тому ся справа що мова йде
про підпрацьовує для того щоб абсолютно
правильно ми говоримо про те що що що І
нічого поганого в тому немає що що
студент під час того як навчається так
само і дещо працює ми маємо відійти від
цієї ідеї що е дитина може жити на на на
стипендії насправді ми маємо розуміти що
ця стипендія це достатньо така Ну
допомогова штука мається на увазі що для
кращих ми даємо стипендію Але разом з
тим абсолютно нормальним є те що дитина
ми зараз маємо інший законопроект який
проходить і так званий індивідуальні
освітні траєкторії де студент має
можливість регулювати своє навантаження
Таким чином щоби так само і поєднювати
навчання із роботою тому що це ну в
сьогоднішніх умовах абсолютно неохно і
ще наостанок от для студентів державного
фінансування якщо приймуть цей
законопроект стане більше але
університетів менше адже міносвіти
планують скоротити кількість вище 170 до
100 от приміром вже там об'єднали у
Миколаїві будемо лякати людей 170 100 і
так дальше це це це великі цифри це
забере великий час але так чи інакше
укрупнені університети дають кращу
якість тому що є кращі можливості для
вибору студента своєго предмета
відповідно мова йде про те що ми хочемо
зробити не маленькі університети де там
10000 чи там 1000 студентів тому що там
якість навчання Переважно я не буду
казати всюди Але переважно вона є нижча
вона є гірша ніж якість навчання в
нормальному університе і де буде там 57
10 000 студентів Отже мова йде про певну
модернізацію мережі і так само що дуже
важливо наші донори на сьогоднішній день
в межах якраз можливостей відновлення
України дають нам певні кошти на
покращення інфраструктури цих об'єднаних
е закладів вищої освіти Отже мова йде
про те що ми вкладаємо гроші в
лабораторне обладнання ми будуємо
будинки ці речі які потрібні для того
щоб модернізувати нашу мережу І от
коротенько так трішечки відійдемо від
нашої теми глядачка Пише доброго ранку А
якщо дитина чистий гуманітарій знає
чотири мови ненавидить математику а вона
є в ЗНО оце біда це не біда навпаки ця
дивіться по але бали то в ЗНО вже будуть
нижчи то буться поперше буде Давайте так
є чотири предмети на ЗНО абсолютно
правильно і нам потрібні людей які
будуть так само знати математику і знати
історію України і знати українську мову
і четвертий предмет в переважній своїй
більшості це буде англійська мова це
абсолютно нормально нам потрібно дити
тину яка вийде зі школи яка буде мати
певний певний ну цілісні знання які
виходять зі школи це є ціль ЗНО тепер
коли дитина вступає наприклад абітурієнт
вступає там на історію чи на філологію і
так дальше то вартість тої частини яка
йде по математиці набагато менша ніж
вартість тієї частини яка йде наприклад
на українську мову чи на історію І це
нормально але все-таки ти мусиш здати
математику ти не можеш бути повний неук
в математиці тому що вибачте мені це
людина входить у вищу освіту і у вищій
освіті люди мають знати і математику і
мову і іноземну мову і власну історію це
такий собі Якщо хочете базовий набір
Який потрібний для того щоби вчитися за
кордоно в більшості вони включаютьправді
в Європі в Європі в переважаючий
більшості є п'ять предметів п'ять
предметів на випуску з школи на вибір чи
обов'язкові три обов'язкові математика
серед них однозначно і пізніше два на
вибір Ну от бачите на сам кінець ще
хотілося б обговорити Я думаю що будуть
зустрічі про мотивацію нашої молоді яка
нині за кордоном До речі вдвічі
скоротилась кількість студентів тут в
Україні а під час повномасштабного
вторнення
потійте чекайте чекайте давайте
секундочку давайте не буде лякати
людейбіль зменшення кількості людей
студентів Це через те що ви не родите
дітей от дуже проси я як батько чотирьох
маю право це сказати слухайте У кожного
своя доля я розумію Я до того щомограчна
си в Україні така що в нас є
інфраструктура яка була побудована на
одну кількість студентів і на
сьогоднішній день В нас є набагато менше
студентів оце через те що 17 років тому
Та ні 17 років тому родилися менше і
постійно в нас кожного року родяться
менше так люди виїжжають але погоджуєте
за цей час виїхало скільки молоді
талановито молодь української яка
закінчує вихід там за кордоно а якість
освіти в Україні має бути змотивована І
високою стипендію і якостю тої самої
освіти і повернення тако а я хочу
сказати що статистика зараз показує про
те що за останній рік більше повернулося
студентів ніж виїхали студентиів з
різних причин але насправді перше якщо
коротко сказати тому що студенти
голосують ногами побачивши яка є якість
освіти там вони починають бачити що в
Україні насправді стереотип про те що в
нас неякісна освіта неправдивий в нас
абсолютно якісна освіта так не всюди в
нас є проблеми очевидно з дуже як
називається Стрімка піраміда якості це
означає що наші кращі хороші а дальше
йде проблема але ми маємо однозначно
непогану непоганий рівень вищої освіти і
на сьогоднішній день якщо подивитися на
наших студентів які побували на заході і
мають всі можливості залишатися в Європі
і так дальше достатньо масово
повертаються на сьогоднішній день в
Україні але з іншого боку ми розуміємо
що структура освіти як сама освіта і
освітній процес має унікальну свою вже
нароблену таку історію що під час
війни давати якісну освіту - це
унікальний досвід саме України
сподіваємося що на наступні роки і
будуть більше можливостей і цим досвідом
буде користуватися будь-хто і той хто в
системі освіти викладає той хто буде
навчатися Спасибі заступник міністра
освіти і науки з питань вищої освіти
Михайло виненський був сьогодні з нами в
отриті ми рухаємося далі Спасибі
д